merci vont le faire s'il est là alors
valérie bénaïm est là bien sûr et on
embrasse valérie merci d'être avec nous
dans un instant vous dire aussi pourquoi
valérie benaïm n'a ne s'est pas exprimée
d'égal ces départs à 8 bat vous allez
parler vous aurez le mode à saint-valery
je vous le dis vous aurez le bois de là
je suis pas bien là je peux les voir
moi j'ai appris que j'étais pas
sensuelle donc je suis je suis je suis
pas dépenser plus que thierry moreau -
non mais c'est vrai bon alors si c'est
important c'est plus non mais non dit la
vérité il n'en veut pas de pitch au sexe
et plus j'ai pas essayé
j'aime les défis
alors l'egypte non c'est juste un
plaisir à meille exactement allez allez
tout de suite une question bon show je
m'appelle delphine la semaine dernière
valérie bénaïm vous a obligé à vous
déguiser en amanda lear est ce que comme
moi vous pensez que c'est une pourriture
vous allez comprendre chez vous vous
allez comprendre la personne alors là
des files je m'attendais pas du tout à
cette piste
parce qu'elle vit avec elle mais je vais
vous répondre oui c'est une pourriture
est ce que vous voulez notre question
cyril merci une question merci non mais
la raison il a raison bonjour je
m'appelle france je voulais savoir si
vous montrez vraiment où les offres de
l'émission ou si vous en censurer
certains parce que finalement vous avez
un coeur parce que brigitte hébert
sachez quand ils font tout ce qui se
passe pendant les pubs ou ce qui se
passe pendant les pauses ce qui se passe
quand on ne voit pas la caméra parce
qu'il parle aussi pendant l'émission
pendant les reportages au petit trot
donc voilà oui c'est une très bonne
question chère france et je vous rassure
je n'ai pas de coeur jusqu'à présent je
cachais bien quelques aof par charité
mais budget de moins en moins d'amis
dans cette équipe je vais pas faire du
déstockage
par exemple vous le savez nous nous
moquons souvent défaut de français des
marseillais à rio eh ben j'ai un scoop
quoi une nouvelle région va partir en
vacances les vosgiens a priori jean
michel seurat chef de bande
aux allumettes non mais quelle
catastrophe
franchement vous a vu quand il parle à
une femme en peluche imbert fourier
jamais savez incroyable non voilà bien
trop séducteur ou bien élevé et valérie
excusé lit vraiment vous avez le droit
de vous exprimer lemire aux allumettes
bravo champion après une fille qu'elle
focus
aujourd'hui c'est ça la chance que je
donne toi d'abord soit excusé bosnie
mais ce que cela donnerait un petit
bisou à valérie parce que là ça avec la
suite vous allez comprendre façon il
peut pas s'en empêcher les émissions de
télé réalité il n'ya pas que des fautes
de français il ya aussi des expressions
sorti de nulle part
là nous regardions un extrait de l'amour
est aveugle
un peu élégant quand même il faut dire
que l'amour est aveugle au père
surprenant chez jean-michel on va faire
un petit jeu on va faire un petit jeu si
vous voulez bien regardez cet extrait et
vous vous allez devinez la suite elle
était très jolie jeu franchement pas une
démarche facile est très jolie alors
d'après vous pourquoi jean michel trouvé
la jeune fille très jolie à risque il a
séduit tout particulièrement
est ce que tu es cas une idée c'est ben
il était plutôt nickelés plutôt nu avec
des nuls avec des gros mais qu'est ce
qu'on a vu qui lui a plu ses yeux ses
grands yeux et ordinaire baird c'est ça
c'est ça ce n'est peut-être pas à les
faire ailleurs plus bas c'est à dire ce
que vous trouverez jamais de façon
nécessaire regardez ce verset pas des
finances
mais tu reconnais même pas ta voix ses
héros sait même pas ce qu'ils disent les
jeunes y avait des poils partout
ben finalement je sais pas s'ils doivent
ou montrer tous les opj à présent de
faire passer les membres de l'équipe
pour des malades alors qu'ils méritent
mieux que ça 1
par exemple il ya deux semaines nous
diffusons un extrait des 12 coups de
midi oui oui une jeune fille réussit à
toucher son nez avec sa langue basque
d'après vous qu'est-ce qu'ils et pendant
ce temps là
sa superficie
allez
mais aujourd'hui c'est ce côté là et
quand même très très inquiétant ne pense
que cela coûte et vaille condamné alors
je pense que leur cerveau ramolli à
cause de la chaleur du plateau car c'est
un vrai fléau la chaleur mais si on
faisait le premier en souffrir ben oui
vous notre maître à tous cyril hanouna
écouter
ok ok bon ben je vous rassure il ya des
gens qui relève le niveau dans l'école
enfin il y en a plus du tout
enora merci quand même vous savez quand
enora danse eh ben elle est très sexy
alors une fois n'est pas coutume pour le
plaisir des yeux un petit cadeau pour
vous
je
c
libre à la fin je suis à l'usiné c
il va des gens dont on va pas se mentir
on a des gros problèmes de sudation dans
l'équipe si si il ya un gros problème et
sa part la température tout va bien tout
va bien nulle part non pas encore et
vous brigitte ça va bien bon très bien
si vous avez la fraîche surtout faites
attention ça paye et des groupes de
sudation est un autre exemple
le fou qui commence
si vous économisez les plus tôt lundi
attention tu sud sous les bras comment
tu sud sous les bateaux aussi connard
mais c'est hallucinant l'agressivité
jean-michel si je le jure les deux pires
c'est vraiment laid dollars jean michel
et valérie j'ai beaucoup il en parlait
la semaine dernière je vous avais fait
un petit palmarès des vacheries que jean
michel balland sur tout le monde mais
c'est dommage est rare que tu devais pas
être là parce qu'il est il a parlé de
toi la semaine dernière ah oui c'est
vraiment dommage
allez pour le plaisir il parle de lui
c
c'est le pire pu prendre vraiment j'ai
donné ma chance vraiment mais le
problème avec jean michel c'est qu'une
semaine plus tard je peux refaire une
autre copine tellement le mec est
prolifique et franchement ça force le
respect donc pour rendre hommage à ce
génie de la langue de [ __ ]
après six deuxièmes mais chose que
j'adore je n'ai jamais fait un bisou à
neuf et le fait alors sur la bouche sur
la bouche
si tu veux jamie benn a vécu plus de la
gueule
qui doit patron
il
ouais on a écrit sur du plus mauvais
papier et d'amour
non
espace patrie jamais jeandupeux - louis
abuserait pourquoi parce que je suis
gamin je suis sûr de rire alors oui
c'est sûr de rien mais on peut partir à
moi si j'étais prêt reer alors sa geôle
york quand vous allez le voir tout nu
vous avez
aah et c'est trop cool j'ai tiré au sort
en parachute ainsi vous avez sauté dans
chute libre
ah oui d'accord si vous êtes aussi très
beau signal
est-ce qu'on va pas dire qu'en un peu on
sème on est des frérots on sent prête
des excuses c'est nul j'aurais quand
même revenir sur l'extrême concernant
quelle origine aujourd'hui c'est
vietnamienne voilà qui va désengorger de
la famille je veux redire deux groupes
sur l'extrême concernant je reviendrai
pas sur la blague sur la taille du zizi
puisque ce thème représente environ 75%
de l'oeuvre de jean michel maire non je
veux revenir sur le rire de thierry
brault qui a suivi j'ai jamais entendu
ça ça s'appelle le rire en accélération
autrement dit le rire de moteurs de
zodiac regarder aura que maintenant j
quand elle a eu une fausse joie
il a cru que la musique partait il a
commencé à kiffer et puis non ce que je
préfère c'est le petit mouvement
derrière
il faut le savoir gilles a une
particularité quand il danse il est
réglable d'arrêter la machine d'un coût
qu il ait va doucement pour éviter le
pépin musculaire
regardez la différence avec isabelle
morini bosc le temps de freinage est
beaucoup plus long
et pour finir sur une note positive
grande nouvelle c'était à priori
impossible mais valérie benaïm a perdu
la première place du palmarès gens vous
savez ce classement des flatteurs de
cyril hanouna la semaine dernière enora
était interviewé à l'occasion du
lancement de son émission derrière le
poste une enora nature qui a profité de
cet entretien pour des vols et les
ingrédients qui font vraiment le succès
ne touche pas à mon poste et les gens
viennent voir cyril hanouna et puis
après viennent voir cette espèce de
petite famille parce qu on est une
famille avec la cousine insolente
le tonton libidineux je vous laisse
deviner qui sait le pape ira leur enfin
et puis le cousin créé des blagues et
puis la douce et soyeuse merveilleuse
valérie enfin je sais pas quoi vous dire
les gens vient de voir tout ça et jean
lui évidemment tout ça c'est bien passé
parce qu'ils manquent des gens
connaissent
et n'aura été plus généreuse sur
d'autres sujets tout de suite le nouveau
palm à des chats elle est produite par
cyril elle avait donc son mot à dire
elle rentre directement en troisième
position c'est ariane massenet c'est un
garçon qui est extrêmement pressé il
répond aussi à une époque il sait
comment accrocher été spectateur ccc un
animateur hors pair
c'est dommage à ryadh si tu avais dit
que c'était un génie tu serais deuxième
elle était en tête depuis plus de trois
semaines
elle est maintenant numéro 2 valérie
bénaïm avec son tube qui nous arrache
des larmes
le vendeur de frigo cyrine c'est un type
incroyable c'est un bac leur incroyable
il a compris que dans tokyo il ya
d'autres ayant un show
il ne dit pas de gros mots par exemple
essayer de trouver cyril des
environnements et nous rase toi les
couilles des amateurs moi je vais les
classés en deux catégories ya ceux qui
sont capables d'être debout pour animer
une émission de télé puis à ceux qui ne
sont pas capables d'être debout
les bateleurs les types qui te vante un
frigo alors qu'il fait déjà moins 15 et
voilà et fait partie de cette école là
ancien numéro 2 enora malagré bouleverse
tous les pronostics et prend la tête du
classement avec son nouveau single bébel
peu commune ça c'est certain
animé par un homme peu comme un sursaut
savez on a longtemps ce pour moi c'est
le jean paul belmondo de la télé on a
souvent dit que c'était le guignolo est
en fait c'est le magnifique
sachez le
conscient il vous en dis des conneries
et passer devant vous bravo au rabais et
dans mes conneries s'est pas posée mais
c'est la surenchère falloir vous bouger
de garantir le bon jour je m'appelle
nicolas je ne regarde votre émission que
pour valérie bénaïm que je trouve
magnifique et j'avais une question est
ce que vous ne trouvez pas dommage qu
une aussi jolie femme soit une
pourriture